العديد من الاسئله تطرح حول مستقبل ترامبا
السياسي وامكانيه ترشحه من وراء القضبان
في حال ادانته وهذا بعد مطوله لاول مره
امام محكمه فيدراليه على خلفيه تهم جنائيه
سابقه في تاريخها
للسباق الرئاسي حتى في المنعطفات الاكثر
خطوره فبعد مثوله للمحاكمه التي تضمنت
توجيها 37 تهمه جنائيه وفيدراليه بينها
سبع تهم تتعلق بالاحتفاظ غير القانوني
بمعلومات تتعلق بالامن القومي والتامر
لعرقله العداله قال انه غير مذنب ونفى كل
التهم الموجهه اليه واشار الى انه ضحيه
لمقاضاه انتقائيه وذات دوافع سياسيه وبان
الرئيس بايدن هو الاكثر فسادا
اليوم شهدنا اكثر نهار فيه شر في تاريخ
بلادنا لم نرى يوما رئيسا سابقا يتعرض على
يد خصومه لما عشته اليوم كل هذا في خضم
الانتخابات والسباق الرئاسي هذا ما يسمى
بالتدخل في الانتخابات من اجل سرقتها
والاهم من ذلك انه اضطهاد سياسي واضح
في مسار سير العمليه القضائيه يتعين على
المدعين العامين اثبات قضيتهم ومواجهه
الفريق القانوني للترامب طبعا هنا يمكن ان
يطلب من ترامب بعد ذلك تقديم اعتراض على
المحاكمه
وسيحدد القاضي خلالها شروطا للافراج عنه
حيث ان العمليه القضائيه قد تمتد لفتره
طويله وهو ما يطرح تساؤلات حول امكانيه
ترشح ترامب للانتخابات خلف القضبان من
الناحيه القانونيه يمكنه ذلك الدستور
الامريكي لا يفرض سوى ثلاثه شروط للترشح
وهي ان يكون مواطنا امريكيا بالولاده وان
يبلغ من العمر اكثر من 35 عاما ومقيما في
البلاد مده 14 عاما على الاقل مساعد ترامب
السياسيه غير مهدده والايدانه لن تمنعه من
الترشح حتى وان سجن يمكنه الدخول الى
السباق الانتخابي ولن يكون سابقه في
الولايات المتحده ففي عام
1920 خاض المرشح ذو التيار الاشتراكيه
الانتخابات خلف القضبان ونال نحو مليون
صوت وهو ما يزيد عن ثلاثه في المئه من
اجمالي عدد المقترعين في ذلك الوقت
التاييد الجمهوري ايضا يلعب دورا مهما
فلقد كشف استطلاع لرويتورز ان 81% من
الناخبين الجمهوريين يرون بان التهمه
الموجهه لدونالد ترامب لها دوافع سياسيه
بحته هنا يجب ان نشير الى ان حملته
الانتخابيه جمعت نحو اربعه ملايين دولار
في الفتره التي تم توجيه تهى من جنائيه
وهو مؤشر واضح على زياده شعبيته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات